what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today i get to watch
thor eleven thunder at the world
premiere i'm super excited thank you to
marvel and disney for inviting me and
did you guys just see that marvel
released a trailer about a couple of
hours ago that had a lot of really
interesting new footage they actually
showed celestials let's take a look at
that new footage real quick because
there's some stuff that i want to talk
about right before i see the movie
tonight
[Music]
okay so there are two
celestials in this new thor love and
thunder trailer and it's very apparent
that they are there they're very obvious
about it in this trailer they're at
olympus so i'm wondering what the
connection here now i would assume that
celestials kind of created the gods but
they are at the same time gods
technically they're both gods the
celestials are definitely stronger than
just a god like thor or a god like zeus
but we actually don't know at this point
in time because that's what this movie
is going to do they're going to
introduce different types of gods in the
actual mcu so eternals has set us up for
the celestials we know how big they are
how massive they are we know their
importance we know their roles and then
we're going to be introduced to zeus
gore the god butcher who i'm sure is
going to be shown you know killing a
bunch of different gods which is where
you know in turn we'll be meeting a lot
of different gods as well and we know
how marvel does it right before you know
the the movies come out they always try
to release a bunch of different tv spots
and clips whether it's on youtube
twitter instagram a combination of all
of them they love to do that and i'm not
complaining because this really gets me
just even more excited uh i think a lot
of people know
thor is my favorite marvel character um
i really really love thor and i really
love chris hemsworth as thor i think
thor ragnarok was such a dang good movie
and it's definitely my top i would say
top three favorite movies i think it
goes like avengers infinity war avengers
in game
thor ragnarok and i'm hoping
that thor love and thunder can knock it
out of that third spot and if not
hopefully it can hit the top five
because again thor's my favorite hero
and now they're putting the celestials
in this so this just got a lot more
interesting we have the celestials we
have zeus we have gor the god butcher
who is going to be showing us a bunch of
different types of gods hopefully
fingers crossed and overall i think it's
just going to be a fantastic movie tycho
what tt is directing again and of course
he's playing cog i love korg that that
was probably really bad but i'm not
sorry about it because i love everything
about it um he did an amazing job with
ragnarok and
it's an even better cast than before
adding natalie portman and christian
bale like two
amazing
actors like i'm so excited for this um
of course natalie portman has been in
the first two but now she's back because
she wasn't in ragnarok so i'm excited to
see that story play out the movie looks
hilarious just like thor ragnarok was
and here's what to expect from me
because i see it tonight
i'm going to immediately post uh kind of
like a reaction if you followed me for a
little bit you know that when i go to
the world premiere premieres of these
movies you know i just kind of walk out
of the theater i'm typically with a
bunch of other youtubers like the real
rejects uh eric ross from new rock stars
uh chris across from culture like i'm
usually with a bunch of different people
uh wendy and dustin and the movie couple
and typically we'll just kind of
take out our phones and just
share our reactions right outside of the
theater right when we get out of the
movie so expect that tonight um
it starts at 7 pacific time i'm assuming
i'm going to get out around 9 9 30 10.
they don't ever really start on time you
know um
not yet at least so expect it around uh
yeah like 9 30 10 o'clock i'm gonna say
9 30 to 10 30 tonight that's gonna be my
just initial oh my gosh i just watched
thor 11 thunder this is like my reaction
right out of the theater
how i'm feeling right away um and then
i'm just gonna come straight back i have
a place in l.a now um for those of you
who didn't know if you don't follow me
on instagram or twitter uh you should i
do post different types of updates on
there youtube is typically my longer
videos and uh
instagram is where i'm gonna be
vlogging and blogging and talking about
the premieres and everything like that
so you can check me out i think it's
just cosmic warren
uh
i'll look at my handle after this but
i'm pretty sure it's just cosmiccorn and
you can find me um on instagram i will
be vlogging tonight so
i'll be posting a lot but then in the
morning
i think probably like 6 a.m 7 a.m
pacific time i will post
however long it may be 10 minutes 15
minutes of me just kind of
gathering my thoughts and then reacting
to
what i saw to thought you know it's more
than just oh my gosh i just watched
throw love and dinner this is going to
be me sitting down
and truly thinking about what i saw and
giving you my reaction it's not a full
review i can't do a review yet so there
will be no spoilers in that whatsoever
it's just pretty much going to be me
going
wow i did like this and this and i kind
of was on the fence about these things
or you know hopefully i'm like wow i
loved everything
um so yeah but final predictions for
thor love and thunder i'm actually glad
this trailer came out because now
i think it skews it i think the gravity
of this movie is going to be a lot
bigger
than we actually realized uh same thing
goes for miss marvel i'm not going to do
any spoilers in case anyone hasn't seen
episode 3 but there's a lot of bigger
connections happening now uh in that
show connecting to other movies actually
and future movies and i think this is
the same thing especially with this
celestial scene right here
in olympus with zeus like that's really
big i'm assuming zeus
is
stronger than thor maybe even stronger
than odin we've seen the flick where he
just simply flicks off of you know he
flicks thor's clothes off
and that's a pretty good sign of power
just a little tiny flick from a really
long way away and just flicks all of his
clothes off i'm assuming zeus is
probably stronger than thor uh and
whether that's just because he's been
around you know a few thousand years
more or many thousand years more uh who
knows right
um but celestials are in
olympus here like
that's pretty big and it looks like
they just chill there so are they just
chilling with zeus because you know it
depends on what type of mythology you
follow and of course we have the mcu uh
mythology or comic origins you know
whatever you want to call it um
but the way the eternal set up the
celestials kind of made it seem like
there really wasn't anybody stronger
than the celestials now of course if you
read comics you know that there are a
lot of different cosmic entities and yes
there are different cosmic entities that
are stronger than the celestials and
especially zeus not trying to downplay
zeus at all but we know that the mcu and
the movies change things
so i'm sitting here wondering
what's the deal like whose city is this
does it belong to celestials and zeus
runs it or is it zeus's and the
celestials just sort of stop by because
it's a fun place to hang out uh maybe
zeus can actually protect them because
we have seen the severed head of a
celestial before because that is the
place nowhere
right that's where nowhere is and i'm
thinking that gore cut the head off
because you know that's a similar thing
that happens in the comics with uh the
whole null and gore storyline
i'm thinking we might see that
especially with the guardians in the
very you know beginning of this movie or
however long they're going to be in the
movie um there's that big connection to
nowhere right there so
we know that gore the guy butchers out
hunting gods maybe the celestials
actually seek refuge at olympus and they
seek the help of zeus and other gods
that may be there because there's this
crazy guy out there going around
murdering gods that's actually what i
think
is kind of happening in this in this
movie and i'm all for it i i really am i
don't think it's good that all the gods
see group together it's kind of lining
it up for gore right there but that's
what i think is going to be happening in
this movie
um and the only thing i have kind of a
question about is at the end
is score going to kind of be good
um you know kind of like i was wrong you
know not all gods are bad
and
i'm sorry uh
my bad but i think that i think he's
going to do that like as he's dying
right he's going to fight thor and thor
is just going to say i'm sorry that you
know the gods weren't there for you
i'm sorry we couldn't save your family
and through this whole journey i think
gore is gonna be like okay not all gods
are bad
and unfortunately i think it's gonna be
as he dies i think he's gonna die um
i definitely think he's gonna die i
don't think natalie portman is going to
die because she does die in the comic
story line eventually uh the cancer
kills her
i don't think she's going to die i know
she has cancer in this movie but i don't
think she's going to die i think she's
going to be around for a bit i also
think chris hemsworth is going to be
around for a bit so i don't think thor
is going to die either he better not or
i'm going to be
mad so uh those are pretty much my final
predictions um
i'm really excited to see it tonight and
i wanna say thank you to everybody who
has supported the channel uh whether
it's been for a day or it's been for
four years i super appreciate you um
you're the only reason i'm here right
now and trust me i i know that and i'm
extremely extremely grateful so
thank you and tonight look out for my
quick little reaction and tomorrow
morning look out for my longer reaction
where i can give a little bit more
detail about what i saw but overall i'm
super excited i hope everybody else is
too i hope this movie's amazing and i'll
see you all i'll see you all tonight
love you all three thousand love you on
every universe
you